[Music]
waiting this long the ash wasting this
much of a cigarette but also cigarettes
i sure hope this individual isn't
intended to be our protagonist because
this is a level of littering i just
can't get behind i swear to the sin gods
if there are robbers in this alley and
pearls dropping from a broken necklace
in this scene sporadic strobe light
reading okay three two one it's jam show
gives us a very somber film noir style
cold open complete with dramatic rose
zoom immediately followed by this
hyperkinetic jazzy opening titles i
think i like both but the point is my
boner's very confused right now i'm sure
all of this imagery will make sense as
the series progresses but right now
feels like the illegitimate love child
of a james bond opening song and an
ocean style heist montage and just as
[ __ ] long practicing unprotected
space travel shadow puppet practice
blasty bunsen calm down time staring
into the sun waving with your toes
vegetables fisting peeing while cooking
showing your crotch to the wall sweating
excitement this profile was clearly put
together on a friday by somebody who had
already mentally checked out for the
week asteroid is an extraordinarily
vague home address in this break
president needed c of course it's
probably down to an issue with the
translation from the original japanese
into english but sending that would be
mean do we seem mean to you there's no
beef in here so you wouldn't really call
it bell peppers and beef now would you
spike would be bop at tv since what
happened to the million wulong reward we
got for that last guy the repair bill
for that cruiser you wrecked and the one
from that shop you trashed and the
medical bill from the cop you injured
kill the doe this all feels like the
spike should have known so either he's
so malnourished he's beginning to lose
his grip on reality or the show felt the
need for an early exposition dump i
shall in return dump two sins upon it to
cover both eventualities also i'm
immediately confused by the rules of the
society's justice system these cowboys
have damaged private public and police
property but because they paid to get it
all fixed there's no further
consequences no jail time what kind of
[ __ ] up society would allow the super
rich to just buy their way out of oh
sure maybe judd is frustrated by spike's
lack of self-control which caused them
to be broke but don't you disrespect
chopsticks like this it's too much this
entirely overflexed toe attention
we will be arriving at a destination
so shortly that you had no choice but to
play this message in multiple languages
at the same time if it's important
information wouldn't it be helpful for
the passengers to actually understand it
oh rivets and moving metal bits so neat
i must have missed the part where i'm
supposed to have an interest or desire
to watch 45 seconds of every launching
spacecraft in excruciating detail wait
where are we didn't jet just say word is
he's hiding out with some sweet thing in
tijuana but this looks less like mexico
and more like an asteroid with a
habitable dome i suppose this place
could be called tijuana as well but that
seems needlessly confusing why not
asteroid 1701 or asteroid based alpha or
i don't know new tijuana newt dorp this
[ __ ] appears to be hanging out of the
window and that must be breaking some
kind of law this again son of a [ __ ]
right another pair of aces in a poker
hand cliche so predictable does no one
know how to ash in this world
[Music]
breast gawking rocking i'm gonna need a
little proof let's have a demonstration
we soon see that this drug has an
extremely intense effect on the human
body how is asimov expecting to conduct
the rest of the deal in this hyped-up
state does he have to do this every time
he tries to move the product surely
there's an independent way of checking
the veracity of the drug without having
to use it none of this even makes sense
unless asimov knows that someone is
going to choose this exact minute to
burst in has he seen this episode
already also i'm not one to judge the
various apparatuses in which one may
choose to deliver drugs but weren't
there better options to administer this
substance did it need to be a prickle
poof why not an eye drop mix some saline
and avoid accidental retina piercing
apparently these old men and even this
[ __ ] cat survived this being a dick
to beer possibly the greatest scent of
them all ah beer this is real mystic and
all but uh do you have anything to eat
here saying spike is clearly an [ __ ]
i'm amazed the director didn't have him
grab an apple from this giant crate back
here the swimming bird will meet a woman
the bird will be hunted by this woman
and then
death aren't these types of predictions
supposed to be much more open to
interpretation like the ethereal sinner
lap dances at midnight on the souls of
cliches or something i mean he's changed
the names but otherwise this is exactly
what happens at the end of the episode i
can't even send it for foreshadowing
because it isn't really foreshadowing if
we're just being told exactly what's
about to happen so yes it would appear
i'm sinning it for not being able to
properly sin it
suck it also how much [ __ ] sand does
this guy have in his hand so you're
hungry too huh baby mechanophilia
judging by the amount of [ __ ] in the
grocery bag i can only assume it's made
from some sort of super advanced space
tree paper that allows it to defy the
accepted norm of grocery bag physics but
since no one involved with the show
decided to clarify that fact i'll just
have to accept it for the impossibility
that it is sin it and move on with my
day for a hot dog lips cannot stretch
that far believe me i've tried also what
the [ __ ] is this hot dog bun made out of
that it meant it could survive the
salivary interior spikes mouth
completely intact come on paper bags hot
dogs cats is everything in the future
indestructible i can't tell when you're
joking when you're not tbsen's comment
section somehow ends up in the episode
who are you i'm just an old-fashioned
cowboy you're a bounty hunter yeah
that's right what in the tarnation was
the point of all this bebop subterfuge
spike went through if he was just gonna
reveal he was a darn cowboy bounty
hunter before he got the chance to
capitalize on the advantage of florida
by said subterfuge it's either supreme
stupidity or astronomical arrogance a
sin either way
that's enough let him go but why she's a
killer in a gang or being hunted by a
bounty hunter why stop asimov from
killing spike while they have the upper
hand oh spikes in more than one episode
isn't he i'm cashing in my chips on this
one it's impossible to catch the guy
there's no way to win it why is jet
giving up so easily with hardly any
effort spike managed to get within
inches of their target and even had an
odds-on chance of catching him if he
hadn't decided to blow his own cover
asimov's escape had nothing to do with
his own skill or cunning and everything
to do with spike's cocky cockiness he
nailed you huh i
i don't think that phrase means what you
think it means the red-eyed coyote will
appear in the zona norte at the far end
of town thank you cowboy bebop for
helping me discover my new code text for
sexy time these ships will be important
later but if we know who they belong to
police rival syndicate space rotary club
who knows you were always planting seeds
of a different kind though insemination
jokes which genius put a seating area in
front of the [ __ ] hotel information
board do you know how much you're worth
i don't know man i've been dealing with
a lot of self-doubt recently sure i'm
making people laugh but am i actually
adding value to a society 2.5 million
wulongs that's your bounty oh sorry i
thought we were having a moment never
mind you look surprised you look
ridiculous in that outfit poncho shaming
the drugs are let loose just because the
fabric on her dress ripped why wouldn't
they be in some sort of secondary
satchel underneath the dress now that i
think about it without said satchel how
are they even keeping the form of a baby
bump and how is she not rattling like a
thousand cowboy spurs with every step
also female character hides something in
her not really pregnant belly cliche how
you doing kid rotten you're late jet
let's just assume that they agreed on an
appropriate time and place to meet off
screen what possible reason could jet
have to be late it's not like he hit
rush hour traffic in his [ __ ]
aircraft feels like the show wanted its
dramatic jet jets to the rescue moment
logic be damned and i'm not standing for
it
[Music]
i have to say man i'm really digging the
vibe of this jazzy neo noirness set
against a backdrop of some space cowboy
bounty hunters take one sin back you
crazy cats
[Music]
this future version of mars sounds
pretty incredible but is it really their
only option space is pretty big why not
stay on the run for a little bit longer
i suppose there's not much you can do
when a character is determined to have a
one episode arc
if i went to a barbecue and there was no
meat i would say yo goober where's it me
this again son of a [ __ ] i'm sorry that
last hand nearly killed me it's over
9000.
they don't like it when you shoot at
them i'll work that out myself
[Music]
ever been to mars get your ass to moss
you're a bounty hunter i can bring you
in warm or i can bring you in cold yeah
i did a job
i got nothing but trouble since i did it
not to mention more than a few unkind
words as regard to my character so let
me make this abundantly clear i do the
job
and then i get paid i know kung fu
show me
ah